des images de liesse populaire qui
contraste avec un bilan sanitaire
alarmant des dizaines de milliers de
croyants hindouistes se sont rassemblés
près du grange fleuve mythique pour des
prières traditionnelles qui semble
ignorer toutes distances à sion sociale
nous n'avons pas peur dieu est avec nous
c'est de ça dont les gens devraient
avoir peur cela nous fait du bien nous
n'avons pas peur il n'y a pas de camps
la virus
l'inde en situation sanitaire critique
sur la seule journée de ce lundi
168 1912 nouveaux cas de contamination
coville 19 ont été enregistrés l'inde
qui devient ainsi le deuxième pays le
plus touché au monde derrière les états
unis avec plus de 13 millions de malades
du coronavirus pourtant les autorités la
sueur avec 100 millions de doses
administrées en 85 jours
l'inde affirme mener la campagne de
vaccination la plus rapide au monde
devant la chine et les états unis en
janvier les autorités indiennes avaient
formulé l'objectif de 300 millions de
personnes vaccinées d'ici le mois de
juillet une population d'1 milliard 300
millions habitants les autorités
indiennes ont approuvé ce mardi le
recours au vaccin russe foot me lever
pour une utilisation d'urgence